we were at tony hawk's
50th birthday party and you came over
and you were like dude
tell me the story about the wu-tang clan
dude talib quali brought up that story
when he interviewed me the other day
amazing that story just goes around it
just like makes
world tours over and over i know dude
and i'm never
i i never look good in that story dude
what's the story it was okay maybe
it was 2006 the rock the bells festival
which is like a big rap festival
headlined by the wu-tang clan i show up
i'm just
drinking all day i'm out of my mind and
i've just
recently dialed in you know i did this
the the
the double back where i'm gonna flip
back and forth and it's a mangina
but i just i just got dialed in the
double back back flip so i'll flip my
balls into a mangina and then do a
standing back flip yeah
and like so they're gonna have
they're gonna have a um an odb
tribute this two years three years after
odb died
two years and um i go up to memento man
i'm like dude i got it
during the odb tribute i'm gonna get
butt naked
i'm gonna flip my balls back i'm gonna
do a standing back flip
and he's like laughing he's like you
know and
uh and then a little while later he
comes up because you can't do it man
they're going to [ __ ] you up
and i go ah cool man that's what me
would want dude he'd love that
yeah [ __ ] rad so like during the odb
tribute like i remember
meant to me i wasn't so sure but then
[ __ ] but then he just hands me the mic
so i'm like hey so i addressed this
crowd of like this is a huge
outdoor festival there's so many people
and i address this crowd i'm like
i'm i'm like i was in uh
you know protective custody in la county
jail facing
eight years in prison and they told me
that i was in
odb cell because he was in there so much
of the time
so i feel this connection to odb and in
his honor right now
i just get butt naked i do my trick i
hug
odps mom right like after doing it
they start playing uh brooklyn zoo you
know like a couple of big odb hits
and like a couple tunes after the fact
all of a sudden
rayquan just just he's had enough and he
comes over and he grabs he stops
everything
grabs me by my neck because she says
you're going to apologize or i'm going
to [ __ ] you up in front of all these
people and i don't care if i'm going to
jail
like like our brother wasn't here to
defend himself from that
and i'm like and he's got me by the neck
and i'm like i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry i was like i'm so sorry
sorry you know and uh and like and then
i apologize and he let me go and and uh
the concert resumed and and someone came
up to and said hey it's not safe for you
to be here you know you guys so they had
like
they escorted us he did that in front of
everybody
oh on stage in front of everybody and i
have the footage
yeah well i've seen the footage i've
been dying to make this video
i have you have to post it
is get someone from like getting
you know maybe rayquan i don't know have
you talked to him since
i saw rizza at something and i just went
up to him and i said hey where is it
like
you know i want to acknowledge that you
know that like to the extent that that
was disrespectful man like
i uh just you know i want to acknowledge
that that was wrong
and uh [ __ ] that you should have doubled
down and did it again
i'm so sick of public apologies just be
like hey i was drunk i was having a good
time odb had a sense of humor sorry
i mean to be fair there was one time i
did a show with odb
before he died and uh it was at this
like hammerstein ballroom in new york
city and like um
before like uh there are all these
different rooms with shows going on i go
into odb
odb was on stage smoking a big blunt
of pure pcp and i know it was pure pcp
because he said so and he was sharing it
with audience members
i pulled out my little camera and i have
this footage dude to this day
i have this footage of him and like he's
rapping like
there's all these different little clips
that i shot on this thing right he's
just smoking the p
p then next thing you know oh and by the
way he's rapping with his [ __ ] pants
down around his ankles his
his cocking balls completely out totally
out and
uh and and i'm condemning like so like
he was uncircumcised i could tell you
that
because i saw you know you know peter
got an anteater yeah and he's smoking
this pcb ends up like uh
he ends up sitting on the uh the drum
riser he's not even rapping anymore and
then like he just slumps over and passes
out
and i got footage of him like that too
yeah still holding the
blunt and he's just like uh it's always
like
almost like time lapse if i'm just like
where
where was this in new york new york in
new york in uh
2003. and was was he on stage by himself
he was uh i mean he had a bunch of like
his crew on stage okay yeah
do you have any wu-tang stories eric
like that
nothing as close to the power of those
you got any pcp stories you ever do pcp
i smoked pcp when i was 13 i think by
accident like i had like a uh
they called it cloud9 like a joint
dipped in embalming fluid
and it was one of the first times i ever
smoked pot and i was like
man weed is crazy
and everything was like eight bit and
then like years of smoking weed
after through high school i was like oh
that wasn't weed at all but it was like
my
second or third time smoking weed so um
i went up to the rizza at a party one
time
and i was all drunk and embarrassed
myself and wrapped like six bobby
digital songs like in his face and i was
like
i'm such a fan and he was like oh okay
that's enough but like that story pales
in comparison to the power of both
stevo's
odb stories that one while he's alive
the one after he's alive i don't think
that was that disrespectful i think
those guys are just old school
you you meant you you your your
intentions were good and you were coming
back i think that that's what
has said it's not to worry about it he
he had never taken it personally he
wasn't offended
also also rayquan was supposedly the
grouch of the group and rayquan was left
wu-tang and rayquan and rizza beefed for
a long time so
he's kind of like the controversial
member of the group i don't think the
other guys would have done that to you
what was disrespectful about it that you
were naked
hugging his mom i think i put my clothes
back on before i hugged his mom
okay i don't think i was that bad i
think he wanted like a sincere earnest
moment
and he's from like the projects of
staten island that he just sees a naked
drug stevo flipping around and he's like
what the [ __ ] is going on right now and
he's just like
no he wanted to have like a sincere like
a hum
sober humble moment and and i know
his his emotions are valid too but right
if i saw
it if i was dead and somebody was
flipping around naked in my honor i
would be flattered
all right in my defense i [ __ ] nailed
that [ __ ] dude how clean was that
landing on that flip paul the landing is
it's good it's clean
yeah can you can you post that video why
didn't you post it i
could i just like i'm sensitive to the
the fact of it being um you know
like i would want the blessing of uh
of the wu tang you know i would i would
no you got to put it out
okay blessings i kind of want that i
kind of think also
with my producer hat on that the story
is kind of better
without just me telling it but like to
get like maybe raekwon
you know his version of it you know so
like it would be really pretty
compelling
if it was uh it's a little bit of a
group effort yeah we got to do it
justice
it's an intense story it's been on my
whiteboard for a long time
where do you live you you live where do
you live i live by lake hall
what's your age what's your name
while you're at it you show us that
contract i'll give you my ass
if you reached out to rayquaza
he wants to talk to me about that like i
mean it would be it would be obvious and
and
i've seen interviews where rayquan was
talking about it and like he
you know carries a grudge about it you
know like
he's not [ __ ] stoked and and you know
like i would love it if uh
there was a way to tell the story i mean
i don't need to look good in it i don't
like
could care you know like i was uh
completely
you know he can be humiliated and and
i'm okay with that
but i would love it if we could bury the
hatchet i think
fan fan the flames of hatred
yeah he's got the jeff tremaine hat on
over here dude
yeah yeah reach out to him have him like
calm down
let's prank him q a to camera and then
yeah prank him come out behind him with
your balls
like right behind his head and like tap
them
tap them on
[Laughter]
thank you so much for watching this clip
and guess what
i have the number 30 ranked hot sauce on
all of amazon it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude